[Musique]
vous mets un boeuf mais je regarde à
quoi on se dit ok on peut être beau
comme ça à 8h du mat
il se prépare il se lève très triste no
maki c'est là qu'il ya quatre ans les
boules à bavans gerbe avant des deux
heures du mans est pas aussi drôle que
vous voilà comment ça va ben là il est 8
heures ouais ouais et j'ai tant dîner
hier alors pas combien d'essence n'ont
pas clandestins on ouvre la casserole et
on voit une tête de mouton comme ça
franchement c'est le plus gros poisson
d'avril de l'histoire de ces dix ou
quinze vingt dernières années
et j'avoue que franchement si les gens
n'ont pas un peu d'humour
eh bien ils n'ont rien compris en tout
cas c'était un énorme poisson d'avril
un poisson d'avril qui a marché je ne
pensais pas qu'ils marcheraient à ce
point là
je m'appelle thomas va nous faire gober
des militaires je suis une santé bouc
émissaire de cette histoire je n'en
reviens pas moi même si d'inviter
quelques personnes fait soir ça devient
je suis le nouveau jacques mesrine
c'est hallucinant plus est c'est ce jeu
la pression que ce tremplin est repris
par une certaine partie de la classe
politique de certains extraits et c'est
terry
[Musique]
je vous dirais que j'étais très énervé
et que quand on quand on m'énerve
eh bien je suis un petit peu brut de
décoffrage et j'ai dit écoutez bien
entendu je fais des soirées j'organise
des trucs et tous les soirs je fais des
trucs avec des ministres c'était une
blague
bon y'a un moment si on connaît vous
savez enfin la france entière me connaît
on sait que je suis j'ai beaucoup
d'humour que je rigole que je dis
beaucoup de choses mais de là à
franchement je voudrais que les
ministres ont que ça à [ __ ] de venir
chez les pièges en chalencon de son côté
gérald darmanin le ministre de
l'intérieur a expliqué avoir ouvert une
enquête sur cette affaire
finalement il avait menti il s'est
rétracté après l'ouverture d'une enquête
pour ce faire une fausse publicité
m'enfin je crois que publicité qui peut
lui coûter cher
en journée le confinement est donc
dehors en citoyen mais dès 19 heures
retour à la maison
le couvre-feu est toujours de vigueur
jusqu'à 6 heures du matin et ne vous
risquez pas faire de faux certificats
il s'agira alors d'un délit qui peut
vous mener en prison
ces images d'un exploit exploit
incroyable celui d'alexis landau il âgé
de 21 ans
retenez bien son nom il a escaladé la
tour eiffel à mains nues là doivent
elles la tour montparnasse bien sûr la
tour montparnasse à mains nues pour les
gens qui sont sa journée en survêtement
et à tous et je leur mettrais bien 405
euros sale gueule je me radicaliser
j'en ai assez j'en ai assez du mauvais
goût et l'irrespect lorsque je sors dans
la rue il faut absolument que je sorte
avec ça c'est mes chaussettes
hi fi ction et je sais pas qui c'est
dessus encore même vraiment vous savez
pas non je passe des présidentes comme
ça il n'y a aucune sécurité avait le
comité d'accueil tout en haut qui
l'homme qu'il attendait ce que la
sécurité a été a été prévenue évidemment
on ne le fait pas comme ça on se dit pas
un matin on se réveille pas un matin en
disant je vais escalader la tour
montparnasse
il s'est préparé pendant un an un oui il
a mis quarante neuf minutes pour monter
cette tour dans ce qui est assez rapide
quand même 210 mètres dos
voilà je vous laisse en compagnie d'un
autre monument de notre patrimoine pour
la fin de de télématin boys on saura ça
vous plaît pas au niveau sur la lumière
poutine qui est l'homme le plus sexy de
russie ah bah tiens ça c'est un sondage
réalisé auprès de 2000 russe qui oui oh
surprise la présidente 68 ans largement
en tête mans serait justement trop
journée des poules commence à chauffer
maintenant mais parce que la vérité
c'est pas une question de mon grand
c'est là ça se passe dans le oui quand
on regarde le détail de ce sondage est à
deux chiffres intéressants 18 % des
femmes interrogées ont répondu qu'il n'y
avait pas d' homme sexy en russie l
accusé de répondre voilà et 19% des
hommes estiment qu'ils sont eux-mêmes
l'homme le plus sexy de russie et à
resserrer ce pc on vous voit le chef
dans ce on se lève contre ans dans la
tnt selon la culture mais moi dans les
orchestres que je dirige non tu toi y'a
pas de sou est l'amour tous ensemble et
tout ça je mettrai pas en ce moment mais
on a hâte
vous avez le cri du coeur est là quand
il fait chaud les miasmes qui sont des
mouches qui dévore la chair et qui aime
se loger dans les juges dans les forêts
des bébés donc le boulot c'est de
soulever contrôler regardez 249 tous les
montants de fourreaux c'est pas
forcément pour qu'elles sont en forme
il fallait vérifier quoi vous est
phobique de coluche il a la phobie de
coluche qu'est ce que c'est que cette
histoire de faux beat coluche quand
j'étais petit j'ai été vraiment
traumatisé par coluche lors de l'un de
ses sketchs en fait où ils étaient
grimés en clowns veut dire qu'il était
très moche en clown oui non le
reconnaissait quand même
il y avait juste un peu de poudre
blanche mais ça veut dire que par
exemple un film où il n'est pas gris
mais du tout je peux pas comme la tomate
est arrivé qu'au 16e siècle donc après
le moyen âge à la renaissance on après
intégrer la tomate mot début c'était le
gaspacho c'était pas ça du tout moi je
sais qui c'est parce qu'il est fier il
faisait froid parce qu'à l'époque le gaz
n'étaient pas chauds et votre prof des
acquis déjà les restos du coeur quand sa
faute on énorme occase de jeu coupe des
cas la pub en fait c'est vrai qu'il est
toujours à la fin de la pub des rigoles
et du coeur blanc avec cette photo en
noir et blanc qu'est magnifique voix
l'important je vois bien laquelle elle
va écouter vous êtes le premier phobique
de cole vous êtes en coluche au phoque
n'est pas d'autre nom pure
désinformation direz vous car j'ai le
bras long oui mais qui pend là juste à
ça c'est pas vrai
alors j'aimerais faire l'ex pardon si
internet est aussi chronophage c'est en
partie en raison de ce type de vidéo à
succès en l'occurrence il y à plus de 5
millions de vues pour cette séquence
dans laquelle un homme s'apprête à
réparer une terrasse
certains ont tout de suite pensé à
ajouter une ambiance de match de catch
mais pour beaucoup c'est clairement une
scène de dessins animés transposé dans
la vie réelle
[Musique]